pico and dylan are 10 and eight
and senna is six
five five and and obviously baby
brooklyn
what does that conversation sound like
for the boys versus for the girls in
your mind because and chris you have
what daughters what do you think i have
uh
uh three boys and a girl three boys and
a girl so pat in your minds is that a
different conversation with the boys
versus girls or have you even are the
kids even old enough to have that
conversation when you should you when
should you start having these
conversations what age yeah i'm watching
i'm reading right now the cain velasquez
case you guys are following you know
what happened there with the king
velazquez case i don't know if you know
what happened there
i heard something happen tyler you know
what you know the story
yeah he he uh
somebody had assaulted what his
four-year-old daughter yeah
tens if not like a hundred times and he
shot at the guy but hit the father if
i'm not mistaken yeah
so so cain velasquez mm-hmm probably not
a guy's daughter you want to mess with
ufc legend and the guy goes and kills
the guy
kills
he's going after the guy he's going
after the guy but accidentally anyways
so uh he kills that guy or he kills uh
i don't know mr four miles under
downwards sometimes
thirty three men with something called
superior quarterbacks that's according
against blasters with the united bill
early this month after he was arrested
and charged for allegedly trying to kill
a man amongst other things who was
charged himself for allegedly molesting
velazquez's younger
relative right young relative can you
make that a little bit bigger so i can
have known mr velasquez for 11 for 15
years and during this time an active
athlete and ufc represented our company
with dignity always treat others with
respect
dana's talking about he was a model of
example of how professionals should
carry out carry themselves projecting a
positive image ufc white has joined
kumar and other people go a little bit
higher
anyways so kane has helped me more
occasions okay people are saying good
things about them here's the point when
it comes down to kids
it's a very uh
different situation
kids sometimes when they're kids they do
things to each other when they're kids
like i got a call
uh
guys running a real estate office and
their kids both are at the office
young kids okay under 14 under 12
whatever it was
maybe one of them was even four and five
you know young kids that they had at the
office
and they're in the other room doing an
appointment and they come in the two
kids are fooling around with each other
okay
four or five years old okay
and they're like how do we handle this
is this going to mess with their head or
not and they're calling me this is one
the lengthiest conversation i have with
some because they had no idea how to
handle this situation it's a pretty wild
who's fault is it in that situation
right four-year-old small is it a
five-year-old's far they're both uh what
do you call it they're both
so
i'm like dude i'm not i'm not call
somebody and process it with them but
you know you can't do anything with the
kid at this point
my daughter being five years old you
know other kids come to our house and
they're playing and they're going away
you're always worried about when they go
in the room by themselves the doors got
to be open
you know who they're playing with and
adults got to be watching even if you
let a younger kid watch how disciplined
is that kid to watch even if they're 13
14 years old i'm still not comfortable
with that i'm not comfortable with a
uh babysitter under the age of 40 to be
honest with you i know this sounds kind
of weird i'm just not i'm not
comfortable with that i'm comfortable
with a babysitter that's a little older
but i've had many weird conversations
with the boys many weird conversations
with the boys but with senna you have to
talk to the girl from an angle of look
you have something that guys want
and unfortunately there's some bad
people out there and you need to know
you got to process it with them like
he's talking about my concern here
is not as much the kids as it is the
parents
i you know i we had dinner with a parent
the other day and i said so how do you
bring it up to oh i'm not going to bring
it up to them it's very awkward like
what do you mean that's very ugly your
cat is 14 years old i'm not going to
bring it up you got to talk to your kid
you don't think he's already she's
already going through it you don't think
she already knows about sex and other
people are trying to get to you and that
happened at 11 years old with boys
you don't think they're doing it at 14 i
think the challenge in here going back
to chris is
help uh um
shape the mindsets of
uh because i don't think school teachers
are doing it because they're worried if
you do it god bless you offend somebody
with transgender and all these different
you know sensitivities they have what
should parents be thinking about right
now how should they process this well i
think
you know again it's being proactive
and if you need to read a book if you
need to do research if you need help
if you need a professional there's
nothing wrong with that but you need to
at least start having the conversation
and again create the opening
for a child to come to you
and say
i have a question is this okay
is this appropriate
and that's the best you can do and
create that because you can't rely on
the school yes there are internet safety
classes yes there are wonderful
organizations that go into schools to
try to educate kids but at
its
most organic level it's what happens in
the house
and it's the comfort level that they
feel and again it starts you can make
the rules however you want them
computers only in public spaces you know
i control the access to the internet i
control who you talk to on the phone but
at some point they're going to figure
out a workaround
right they're going to get on yeah the
internet yeah and i've had i've given
speeches where fathers say oh just won't
allow it i'll take it away well they can
go to starbucks they go to the friend's
house the entire cities are wired so you
have to say
look
you're protected here this is your safe
area and you're generally safe
everywhere you go
and the reality is when it comes to
predators the vast majority of kids who
are preyed upon are preyed upon somebody
they know
right even though there are
many many scary stranger cases and
i deal with them all the time
so it's really about creating the
comfort level
with the family
to say hey and if you have a daughter
you can talk to your mom if you're
uncomfortable talking to me
but i'm here for you
and there should be nothing off topic
yeah
yeah uh you know
the whole thing when i'm talking about
babysitter under 40. i'm talking about
like guys men women you know it's a
different story when you were doing an
interview and you said in all these
cases you've had with the catching a
predator has ever been a woman and you
said none none right none it's never
been uh it's happened but the the
therapists or the experts in the area
have always said to me that when you see
the female predator scenario you're more
likely to see the teacher student the
female predator does not like the
anonymity where the male predator
sometimes can thrive on it right right
so
but you know it's crazy yesterday i
don't know who we're sitting down with
and we're talking about uh
uh why is it that teachers in florida is
women that are who said that somebody
john said that john said that yes when
we're doing a pbd podcast
prep he says you know florida it seems
like it's the women
teachers who take advantage of young
boys how does that happen how do you
have that camera how different is a
conversation with your sons
traditionally
you know and you hear the comments all
the time like that be a dream come true
or whatever yeah you know it's a fantasy
country for for a young man but it's not
and it's inappropriate
it's not healthy obviously
so
you know look i
you know remember
in public school it didn't happen
brother rice but in public school or in
college you know there were very
attractive
professors tas teachers you know
whatever and there would be chatter
amongst the fellows about that but the
reality is
when it comes to young kids and young
boys it's wrong there's we have ages in
the law for a reason
you know and it's illegal to have for an
adult to have sex with somebody who's
um
a minor
and they
those laws are in place because it's
hard to process how do you talk to your
son about that what do you tell them
like i was 13 years old i'm in eighth
grade my history teacher's name is miss
angulo everyone being sir every one of
us has a teacher what was that one movie
with dustin hoffman yeah the great
graduate right you know it's a legendary
movie so
boys have these fantasy teachers that
they think about that they help them
grow up what do you tell your son
there's no rush
to fulfill this fantasy it's it's
natural to feel it and again i'm not a
therapist i just play one on tv with
predators but
from where i sit
having sons who are 30
28 almost and and the youngest my
stepson is is 20.
um
you know they're out of the woods pretty
much
but when my older ones
were younger you know it's all about
respect it's about you know
don't you don't have to rush into this
right you got your whole life to
experience certain elements
right take your time
be a kid
yeah that's easy to say it is easy when
you're 15 16 and your hormones are
raging and there's a hot teacher ready i
get it i get it i don't know about that
i lived it with you know two boys you
know i walked in
one time and my son will kill kill me
for telling a story but
you know
we left the house
came back drove by going out to dinner
and the front door is open
and i go
and i go in and i go down the basement
he's in the hot tub
with a girl and
you know there are
i don't think they're driving yet and i
all about it i said look
first of all
you can't have a party here without
parents home that's number one number
two
you put her in a situation
where
she could be embarrassed
because you weren't thinking of her
how this may look or appear
so
but they were both what 16 something
like that 15 15
something like that well at the end of
the day there's nothing wrong with it
nothing wrong with it but i had the
conversation right you got to
you got to see how this could look and
what if
her dad
strolled by would you be comfortable
with that
yeah and think about it conversations
are going to work for 15 year olds maybe
i don't know
i just you know let me ask you something
sometimes you pray for the best you know
and hope everybody figures out but i
think if you preach respect yeah
you're halfway there well here's just
another scenario that is a little of a
gray area
because i remember being a senior in
high school and there was like a
freshman girl that the like you're
talking about the laws i was just about
to yeah so how many 18 year old boys are
hooking up with 15 16 year old girls
depending on you're going to school
together like it's not like it's that
big of a difference i joke around with
the girl i dated when i was 18 she was
50. the girl's 38 now with kids that's
like what are we talking about but i
think that's the time it was oh my god
right but at the
that's why in many states if you're 17
15 it's not illegal if you're 30 and 15
it's illegal as it should be
so you know but it's the it's the it's
the 1815 it's the 1916 that's
that's the it's like what is it we go to
high school together we go to school you
know and that's the weird part i'd even
take it a step further that you're
branded for life like i worked with a
guy who i think he might have been 19
and when she was 15 or 16. and her dad
didn't like him and now he's been
branded as a sexual predator they
probably had to register right or even
if like you're drunk and taking a leak
outside and get arrested you're labeled
as well that's that's obviously you know
at some point
you know in some areas we lost common
sense in this right if a 17 in a 16 year
old are dating
and there's an issue
that 17 year old probably should not
have to be prosecuted or registered as a
sex offender i mean that's just common
sense i mean they're within a year or
two of each other and that's why the
laws have changed
now you know if it's the teacher and the
15 year old student yeah different story
different story but i mean we you know
we sometimes in an effort to have zero
tolerance policies yeah
find injustice
uh i think and i don't pretend to have
all the answers but i have seen what
you've said and no you shouldn't if you
get caught
outside a bar urinating in public you
should not have to register as a sex
offender if you enjoyed the short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]